(whimsical music)
(man groaning)
- [Narrator] Golf isn't known for being
the most forgiving game.
- [Man] Shit!
- [Narrator] But there's nothing quite
like shanking your ball
into the drink or pond.
That's where this guy comes in.
Here at TPC Sawgrass, hundreds
of golfers lose their balls
to the infamous par three 17th hole.
But one golfer's misery
is another man's gold.
This is Gordon Davis.
- My name is Gordon Davis,
and I'm a professional golf ball diver.
- [Narrator] And he makes a
living diving for golf balls
all over Florida.
- [Gordon] I've been diving for golf balls
approximately 50 years.
- [Narrator] There are a
lot of balls to be found.
- On average, when I'm diving,
I'll pick up 3 to 4,000.
- [Narrator] 3,000 to 4, 000?
- 3,000 to 4,000.
- [Narrator] Whoa.
So, how do you find these golf balls?
- [Gordon] It's mostly,
you know, just feel,
picking them up out of the mud
and some places the mud's so deep
that you can't do nothing with it, you know?
- [Narrator] And it's that
mud that makes it impossible
to see, well, anything.
- [Gordon] Most courses,
there’s very few that has clear water.
Most of them has poor visibility
because of the algae and all that.
- [Narrator] So what happens next?
- After I pull the balls
out, they go through,
pick out some of them, and
they take them from there.
- [Narrator] They being someone who wants
to repurpose these balls.
- These balls are authentic.
- [Narrator] These authentic
balls are diced up,
placed in all sorts of usable keepsakes
like saw grass, watches,
and bottle openers.
And Gordon, he knows what it takes
to be a professional golf ball diver.
- What I tell people is you
gotta be kind of a special cat
to be a golf all diver, somebody with grit
and that wants to be
an independent person.
It's like any other business,
someone has to do it.
Everybody has a different job
and this happens to be mine.
- [Narrator] Seeing as
you're kind of a special cat,
any advice for golfers trying
to keep their balls dry?
- [Gordon] Yeah, take up another sport.
(laughs) Hole-in-one!